today on the matt walsh show as disney
adds an offensive content disclaimer to
the muppets we'll discuss how leftism
has become
the modern puritanism also five
headlines including fauci's declaration
that we may have to wear masks
into the year 2022 and kendall jenner
faces claims of cultural appropriation
for her new tequila brand in her daily
cancellation we'll talk about
alexandria casa cortez's trip down to
texas to quote help
during the winter storm all of that and
much more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know there are a few things that i
value more
as a parent than the value of a good
night's sleep
and they're also a few things that i
that i that i get less of an opportunity
to have
than a good night's sleep sleep as a
parent but that means that just means
that you got it you got to take
advantage of the time that you have even
if it's only
you know four hours in bed because they
could have kids crying at four o'clock
in the morning for god knows what reason
you gotta take advantage of those four
hours sleep as much as you can
and that's what my pillow is all about
that's why i use my pillows
uh my pillow products they don't go flat
they maintain
their shape you don't have to worry you
know you get regular pillows and they go
flimsy and flat and it's just
it's no good you can wash and dry them
as many times as you want and they
maintain their shape and best of all
they're made
right here in the usa so when you
support my pillow you're supporting
american workers if you don't have a my
pillow or you know someone who doesn't
have one
now is the time to get one because for a
limited time my pillow is offering
their premium my pillows for their
lowest price ever you can get a queen
size
premium my pillow which is normally
69.98 you can get it now for 29.98
that's 40
in savings kings are only five dollars
more
so if you want to try the my pillow now
is the time to do it um just don't wait
around till the deal goes away you gotta
pay a lot more money
now's the time to buy not only are you
getting the lowest price ever but they
are the best
gifts ever too gotta get a gift-giving
occasion coming up a birthday or
anything
then my pillow is the way to go 29.98
for a queen size premium my pillow buy
now and they will extend
the 60-day money-back guarantee to march
1st
2021 go to my pillow and click on the
radio listener square
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets all these
products are awesome
so you gotta check it out and to do that
call 800-651-1148 and use promo code
dailywire
if you're keeping a list of every new
thing that suddenly becomes offensive
well you're probably pretty busy that's
a project which doesn't allow much time
for anything else in your life
a running tally of offensive things
would be like kind of like the us debt
clock if you go to usdetclock.org
and it goes up by about 100 000 every
second
or something like that the offensive
thing list may not grow quite that
rapidly but it's it's getting there
here's the latest
the muppets the muppets are now
problematic
it was revealed recently that disney
plus which just added the muppets to its
streaming lineup
has a disclaimer attached to the
beginning of each episode
the disney disclaimer of course is not a
new concept they've been doing this ever
since they launched
their streaming service a few years ago
already movies like the aristocats
dumbo peter pan lady in the [ __ ] the
jungle book
the mickey mouse club from the 50s even
aladdin have disclaimers because of
their supposedly offensive content
i can only assume that other films must
have them too like mulan for its
stereotypical depiction of chinese
culture pocahontas for the many
inaccuracies in the way that it portrays
elizabeth warren's childhood lion king
ought to get the disclaimer treatment
too for stereotyping the hyena community
the film depicts hyenas as maniacal
buffoons laughing about everything
but of course actual hyenas don't laugh
the laughing sound is a form of a bark
which they use to signal
to the other members of their pack if
they've made a kill or if there's a
danger in the area lion king both
trivializes and
otherizes hyenas not to mention warthogs
toucans
indeed when you're when you're looking
for a reason to be offended by old
cartoons or even recent cartoons
it's not hard to find them if you're
creative enough in your outrage
and would take some especially creative
outrage in the case of the muppets
but our culture is no doubt up to the
challenge here's the warning that comes
with
uh with each episode of that show now
here's what it says
it says this program includes negative
depictions and or mistreatment of people
of
of people or cultures these stereotypes
were
wrong then and are wrong now rather than
remove this content we want to
acknowledge its harmful impact
learn from it and spark conversation to
create a more inclusive future together
mistreatment of people well they're
puppets so i don't know who's really
being mistreated but
this i believe is the disclaimer they
use across the board now
notice how disney excuses its decision
to continue to profit off of content
that it now says
is harmful the company claims that it it
has this
dangerous and offensive material on its
platform
not so that it can rake in millions of
dollars but so that it can
spark conversation and create a more
inclusive future
together i guess sparking conversation
and creating an inclusive future is also
why they continue to sell merchandise
from these shows and films yes that's
why you can go to target
in 2021 and buy a jasmine doll
even though jasmine is from a film with
offensive stereotypes
and she was voiced in the original
cartoon by a white actress
culturally appropriating a role that
should have gone to an actual
arabic princess with a pet tiger and a
boyfriend who rides a magical carpet
around the city
with his wacky genie sidekick it's all
for sparking a conversation you see
and surely the eight-year-old girl who's
given that doll upon
that doll upon receiving it will um
will say to her parents she'll say well
thank you for this gift mother and
father it presents me with an excellent
opportunity to reflect on the impact of
negative stereotypical portrayals
of disadvantaged minority communities
i'm sure that's how it goes
or maybe not see this is why i have to
stop myself
short when i'm tempted to accuse the
contemporary left
of being the new puritans in a certain
way it's true you know they are
leftism is a strange inverted form of
puritanism at least
puritanism in the modern colloquial
sense of the term
leftists are the ones now who seem to be
perpetually offended
fragile needing advisories and
disclaimers and other layers of
insulation from content that might
traumatize them
i call i call it a weird and inverted
puritanism because the left
has also maintained and plunged deeper
into
its hedonistic impulses at the same time
so this they're this very strange mix of
puritan
pure puritan and and hedonist
they still demand that we accept
tolerate celebrate all forms of
sexual indulgence and expression however
strange however unnecessary
unnecessarily public it may be but then
they turn around and
wither like delicate flowers in the hot
sun the moment they hear a slightly edgy
joke
or an opinion that divulges a little bit
uh or rather you know verges a little
bit from their own
or they encounter even a cartoon film
made for children
children who apparently were better
adjusted and more emotionally stable
than themselves you might say to
simplify
that they're offended by all of the
things that are not offensive
and not offended by all the things that
actually are
while they wouldn't want children to be
exposed to the horror of a peter pan
cartoon
they see no problem with kids listening
to sexually explicit
and absurdly degrading songs from cardi
b and the like
it's backwards and that's why calling
them puritans
seems to sort of fit but on another
level it doesn't fit at all
what we can say about the actual
puritans of the 16th and 17th centuries
a group that may be admittedly a little
hard to define
is that they were yes rigid and
close-minded
like the modern left and there's where
the comparison lies
but they were also earnest
and sincere they made enormous
sacrifices to live
by the convictions that they really
deeply believed in and felt
the puritanism of the modern left lacks
that sincerity that conviction that
sacrifice
it's empty at its heart mostly a put on
a display a political performance
a marketing ploy the modern puritanism
of the left is in fact
perfectly encapsulated by a company like
disney
declaring its own harmless cartoons
harmful
and then proceeding to make millions of
dollars off of them see the thing is
i can respect almost any world view to
some extent at least
if the people who harbor that view are
willing to live by it
and so in a certain way the crazier the
worldview the more i am forced to
respect the conviction of those who
abide by it
vegans are completely insane as far as
i'm concerned
but if you actually live the vegan life
and forego the immeasurable joy of
meat and dairy products then i can
respect your follow-through
but when it comes to the woke brigade
and the doctrines that lead it to
declare something like the muppets
harmful and offensive
there's no follow-through there's no
sacrifice there's no conviction there's
no substance
it's puritanism but only the most hollow
and most absurd kind now let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
you know one of the most underrated
aspects of
parenting i think is that you get to
relive
things in your childhood some of the
some of the childhood fun that you would
never you probably wouldn't be able to
have you wouldn't have the opportunity
to engage in if you didn't have kids so
for example over the weekend
we took our kids to a trampoline park
here
in nashville and uh it was a lot of fun
and you know
i was i was probably having more fun
than the kids bouncing all over on the
trampolines it's just a lot it's
just great the thing is if you're an
adult it's the kind of thing that you
should be able to go
and do as an adult but i think if you're
an adult and you don't have kids
you're probably not going to get
together with your like 30 year old
buddies and go down to the trampoline
park so you have to have kids for that
and um so that's what we did
and it was a lot of fun but then the
other problem is that you're an adult so
i woke up the next morning feeling like
i had been trampled
by a herd of goats or something
just i could barely move from jumping on
a trampoline for
30 minutes and maybe that's why adults
stay away from those kinds of things
usually uh
okay number one the media has long since
branded ron desantis
a failure of course in his response to
the pandemic the only problem has been
in in finding a reason for that branding
so they've decided that
he's a failure but there's never been a
reason to call him a failure because all
the evidence all the facts on the ground
point to desantis having the best
response or among the best
out of all the governors in the state in
the country but the media can't allow
that narrative to take hold so they've
been digging
you know getting creative as uh as as
they need to
to find some reason to criticize him
so they've got they know what their
conclusion is
the conclusion is that he's been a
failure in a disaster
now they just need to find reasons for
that conclusion
speaking of things working backwards
that's the way that they go
uh kind of like the opposite of the
scientific method it's the scientific
method
flipped on its head nbc news though
thinks that it's finally found
the reason so here's the report from nbc
news they say
florida's governor was slow to respond
to the pandemic and his covet 19 vaccine
distribution plan has been marked by
chaos
but critics say he's been quick to
recognize the political gold
in those precious doses governor ron
desantis a republican ignored federal
guidelines and prioritized getting
senior citizens
one of florida's most potent voting
blocks vaccinated first
when holocaust survivors and cuban
survivors of the bay of pig
bay of pigs debacle revered members of
the two other key
florida voting blocs got their first
shots desantis made sure he was there
for the news conference
and now the governor stands accused of
using the covet 19 vaccine
to reward political powerful political
supporters and developers
by setting up pop-up vaccination sites
in planned communities they developed
and where gop voters predominate okay so
you see what they're saying here he has
prioritized
seniors the elderly in his vaccine
rollout
that's what they're hitting him for
and it's bad it's bad to prioritize
seniors because
a lot of old people are republican that
is actually what the media is saying
that we shouldn't prioritize the elderly
uh because
too many of them are republican
when of course in reality we know that
obviously the elderly are
the most susceptible to the virus by and
large uh speaking in generalities and so
obviously they should be prioritized
so here we're taking this again is is
ron desantis
showing the right way to do it a lot of
other states have been
disasters in in florida they're doing it
the right way
and this is another case where ron
desantis success is being portrayed
it's not just that they're ignoring his
success they're actually flipping it
around
and saying no this is a failure
meanwhile more coveted news
fauci um dr fauci is warning that
we may have to keep wearing masks all
the way to the year 2022 and beyond
here he is on cnn talking about it
listen you
and the president have suggested that
we'll approach normality
toward the end of the year what does
normal mean do you think americans will
still be wearing masks for example in
2022
you know i think it is possible that
that's the case and again
it really depends on what you mean by
normality
right that's what i want you to define
exactly the way it
no dana it's important because if
normality
means exactly the way things were before
we had this happen to us i i mean i
can't predict that
i mean obviously i think we're going to
have a significant degree
of normality beyond what the terrible
burden
that all of us have been through over
the last year
that as we get into the fall and the
winter by the end of the year
i agree with the president completely
that we will be approaching a degree of
normality
it may or may not be precisely the way
it was
in november of 2019 but it'll be much
much better
than what we're doing right now uh
a few things here first of all this is
what we're hearing now
well it depends on how you define normal
what do you mean by normal what
do we no you know what we mean by normal
this kind of bad faith thing where well
it depends on who knows what normal
means
no everyone understands normal is like
what it was before
just living a normal human life and you
could walk outside your house and you
could go to the store go to a restaurant
you're not covered in a in a in a muzzle
you're not muzzling yourself
um businesses can open up their doors
and
serve as many people as they can fit
inside their building safely you know
that kind of thing that's what normal
means
and but but fauci is saying well we'll
see
and that's what his ants are all along
we'll we'll see what happens maybe maybe
not
and this has been the other thing that
um we're hearing now in fact i think it
was an nbc news article i don't have it
i don't have it in front of me right now
but um this is yeah nbc new york
they have an article up right now and uh
what they
they say this is this is the the tweet
they sent out it says
you're fully vaccinated against the
chronovirus now what don't expect to
shed your mask and get back to normal
activities right away
that's going to be a disappointment if
not a shock to many people
so this is the message that we're
hearing now we've started to hear more
and more we hear from the media we're
hearing it from
the so-called health experts where
they're saying
even after you get both vaccine doses
you might still have to wear the mask no
not not mite you do still have to wear
it
socially distance all nothing changes
not only is this absurd and wrong
but i cannot if you're trying to
discourage people from getting
vaccinated i cannot imagine a better
message
for for anti-vaxxers this is like uh
this is a dream come true
if you're an anti-vaxxer it's a dream
come true that the provax people
this is their message is yeah get the
vaccine but
nothing will change in your life for the
better your life will not improve at all
but please go and inject this substance
into your body anyway
it's not going to do anything for you at
least as far as you can tell in the way
you live your life
but do it anyway that is the
worst message you could possibly send
if you actually want people to vaccinate
if you want mass
vaccination if you want millions and
millions of people lining up to get
vaccinated
and you want to have most of the country
vaccinated in the next few months the
message should be
get the vaccine and you can go back to
your daily life
now that's what i'm saying if if if
that's your goal that should be your
message
um i personally believe we should be
able to get back to our daily life
regardless of the vaccine
i've been saying that for months but
from the perfect perspective of a
pro-vaccine person
that should absolutely be the message
they're undercutting themselves with
this
or we would say they're undercutting
their own you know
goals and intentions if we actually
believe that their ultimate goal is to
get us back to normal
at a certain point we have to grapple
with the fact that a lot of these people
that's why they're trying to redefine
normal or they're getting hazy about
what normal even means
because they never want to go back to
that normal
is that the case for fauci i mean with
fauci it's
we're at the point now where either this
guy
is malevolent um or he is
simply one of the most incompetent
government officials
ever in history those are the two
options
an option that is not available anymore
is the one where we say he's been a
smashing success
there is no evidence that where's the
evidence can anyone come up with one
reason
one what's one thing we can point to if
you believe that fouchy's been a success
like what is your what
point to one thing give me one reason
one piece of evidence for fauci's great
success
no matter how you slice it he's presided
over a disaster
he can't keep his own excuses his own
story straight
where's the success but he is the
perfect example he is in a lot of ways
the perfect government employee
because even though he has presided over
this disaster and he's and he
contradicts himself every two seconds
um and by any measure you look at he's
been a failure
he not only remains employed but he is
what is he i think he's the highest paid
government employee
doesn't just remain employed but he's
the highest paid guy
despite being arguably the greatest
failure
that's what working in the government
gets you now on the other side of it um
so that's the the negative pessimistic
side on the optimistic side here's dr
gottlieb
who was speaking to cbs over the weekend
and he actually had uh
an optimistic take here he is listen the
numbers
frankly look good in terms of the
infection rate going down but we are
about to
cross this morbid uh milestone of half a
million americans dead
where are we in this um and
should we be optimistic given the
infection decline
look this has taken a tragic toll on the
united states but we should be
optimistic in my view
i think we're going to continue to see
infection rates decline into the spring
in the summer
right now they're falling quite
dramatically i think these trends are
likely to continue the new variants do
create new risk i think b117 creates
some risk that we could see
a resurgence of infection in certain
parts of the country and higher
prevalence overall in the spring in the
summer than we might have seen without
this strain
but it's not going to be enough to
reverse these trends at this point i
think it's too little too late in most
parts of the country
with rising vaccination rates and also
the fact that we've infected about a
third of the public that's enough
protective immunity that we're likely to
see these trends continue
the risk is really to the fall and one
last point if you look at the counties
in new york and new jersey that had
greater than 45 percent sarah prevalence
meaning that 40 more than 45 percent of
the population was infected going into
the winter
they really didn't have much of a winter
surge so once you get to about 40
percent of the population with some form
of protective immunity
you don't have herd immunity meaning
that this won't transfer at all it will
continue to transfer but it will
transfer to much slower rate
i mean the reality is that uh as you
just heard there infection rates are
plummeting that's what's happening um
and
it's you hear that if you go if you go
and
seek this information you want to know
what's happening with the infection
rates in the country
you can find it when you google it but
it's not headline news everywhere the
way the bad news is
uh or was but it should be this is great
news
infection rates are plummeting and
they're plummeting even though we're
still
in the winter i mean we were promised
back in the fall if you remember we were
promised
uh a long we were promised a long
horrible winter and and the the
infection rates would
continue to rise and um instead we're
still in the winter
infection rates are going down markedly
dramatically
we haven't even gotten to the spring yet
i'm going to get into the spring with
the warmer weather
and where you get that seasonal effect
on top of the fact more people are going
to vaccinate it and also
just millions of people have already had
the virus and
millions of though majority of those may
not
even know they had it but they did so
there's there's no reason why we cannot
even from even if you're not an ant if
you're an anti-lockdown person like i am
then you've wanted us to get back to
normal life
all along basically but even if you're
not in that camp
even from a pro-lockdown stance
you should still be saying there's no
reason why we can't begin to really get
back to normal now
we're getting out on the other side of
this thing that's great news it's
wonderful news we can celebrate it
we can all celebrate it together in
person
we're not going to hear that from the
media that often anyway
all right next cam newton former
patriots quarterback
also former panthers quarterback was
hosting a football camp for kids
so he invited kids out he's hosting a
camp and
this is a video that went viral
yesterday of
a back and forth he got into with one of
the kids there who was
heckling cam newton and a lot of people
were upset
at cam newton for his response here but
i don't know let's let's listen
you're a free agent you're a free agent
rich you're crazy
what's your dad
okay so the kid is is cussing
at cam newton taunting him for being a
free agent
i don't know i mean being a free agent
in the nfl sounds a pretty good deal
he's going to make millions of dollars
somewhere
um and uh and saying that he's about to
be poor and then cam newton's response
is that he's rich
kind of a dumb response so that he keeps
asking him where's your dad
people are upset at cam newton for that
now i'm no
cam newton defender i don't really have
a general stance on cam newton i don't
care that much
but i don't know how you could watch a
video like that it shows where people's
priorities are i don't know how you can
watch a video like that and
you side with the kid and
in in a situation like this i'm almost
always going to take the adult side
what happened to respecting your elders
this forget about the fact that he's a
natural quarterback who cares about that
he's an adult he also invited you out to
this camp
that he's hosting for you to give you
opportunities
and you're cussing him out and taunting
him
this is how you speak to adults and if
you look at
the at the reaction on social media a
lot of people are saying how dare you
speak to that poor child that way
the kid's lucky that all he did was
speak to him it's lucky you didn't get a
you know
you didn't get a firmer response than
that
this is a kid who has probably not
gotten a lot of firm responses from
adults in his life and that's how this
this happens
all right number four this is from the
daily wire it says model kendall jenner
has been accused of cultural
appropriation after launching a tequila
brand
that she claims to have been working on
for nearly four years in an instagram
post jenner announced the launch of her
tequila brand which is 818 tequila which
is presumably named after the
california area code where i guess i
don't know she lives
jenner jenner said her tequila brand had
already won eight awards including best
um uh eight awards including the some
awards at the world tequila awards
and uh but the reaction on social media
again was
largely negative following her
announcement social media condemned
jenner for allegedly culturally
appropriating mexican culture
one user accused jenner of profiting off
of mexican traditions
uh they said something about kendall
jenner making tequila rubs me the wrong
way
like the idea of white celebrities
taking from local mexican artisans and
profiting off of our traditions and
agriculture business
yet only visit cabos and puerto uh
puerto vallarta
for vacation spots and not to mention
profit off of the brown hands that
actually plant grow
harvest ferment and distill the agave
plants
that are used to make it uh and other
things like that so she's culturally
appropriating from
mexican culture by making it tequila no
i i really love this story
and i love it only because it reveals
again how absurd
the cultural appropriation claim and
concept is
because in reality no i'm i'm no tequila
historian and something tells me that
the people saying cultural appropriation
also are not tequila historians but um
i am aware and i think a very quick
google search will confirm this
that tequila is not historically a
purely mexican
uh innovation in fact i believe it was
spanish conquistadors and maybe someone
who knows a little bit more about this
can correct me if i'm wrong
i believe it was spanish conquistadors
who took a
version of a of an alcoholic beverage
that was common among the natives and
they distilled it and they
they made what later become became known
as tequila
and some of the early popularizers of
tequila were
spanish aristocats aristocrats almost
said aristocats because i had
disney on my brain but some of the early
popularizers
of tequila were spanish aristocrats in
in mexico so this is not
that's tequila it's actually i guess who
is she appropriating from
spain no tequila itself
is a product of cultural blending
and that's one of the reasons why the
cultural appropriation claim
doesn't work as a concept it's absurd
because it's very difficult to look at
any form of cuisine any
you know style of dance any uh
any form of dress anything
any tradition it's very difficult to
look at that
and and trace it back and find
that it's never been influenced it's
never had any outside influences
almost everything that we have today in
the modern in the modern world
whether it's a food it's an alcohol
whatever it is
um it is a product of blending of
cultural cultures influencing each other
and that's because cultures can't own
you know mexican culture doesn't own
tequila
even if native mexicans were the ones
who who
innovated it from the beginning which
they weren't you don't own
an alcohol as a culture cultures don't
own things that's not how culture works
and again you know appropriating implies
that something is being taken from you
that's what it means for something to be
appropriated from you
if somebody appropriates ten dollars
from your wallet they've taken it from
you
and now you don't have that ten dollars
anymore you're out ten bucks
well kendall jenner making it tequila
she's not depriving
tequila from anyone she's not taking it
away from mexican culture
there is no mexican person who can no
longer have tequila or produce it or
sell it because
she's making it that's just not how it
works
all right five finally this is a tweet
from madonna she says
the patriarchy continues to to try to
crush my neck with their heavy boots
cut off my life force and take away my
voice even those who call themselves
artists
you know who you are death to the
patriarchy now and forever
risk what you value value what you risk
yes the patriarchy is crushing her neck
with their heavy boots well i i
only want to note that madonna is worth
i think
800 million dollars 850 million
and she's approaching a billion dollars
that she's worth
and all i can say is if that's what it
means for the patriarchy to crush your
neck then please i'll
i'll lay down the patriarchy crush my
neck if it means 850 million dollars
i'll
i'll take that for 850 million not a bad
deal
that's the thing about oppression in uh
in modern american culture
it's a very profitable business
all right let's go read some of the
youtube comments from the show on friday
this first is from the username is
insert name here too lazy to come up
with his own name i guess
says the dumbest thing ted cruz did was
engage the media and apologize
he's already got a target on his back
and he basically just chummed the water
uh yeah i agree with you i think that
was the mistake he made
there's another mistake that he made
which we'll get to in the daily
cancellation but uh
yes apologizing was was certainly a
mistake
because he didn't do anything wrong
you know he he i think his his initial
statement with the with
when that ridiculous controversy first
erupted
was clumsy and not the right way to go
about it
um but him pointing out that he was
trying to get his family
he he didn't have power either and it
was freezing cold
and so he's trying to get his family to
warmer temperatures what nothing wrong
with that
that's what any good father would do now
for for political reasons which we'll
talk about in a second but for political
reasons maybe the smart move is to bring
your family or to you know
bring them to the airport put them on a
plane and then you stay back
even if there's nothing really for you
to do staying back
but getting your your family out of that
situation if you can
is a smart move and i think it's what
any
any father with the means would do this
is from cool papa j
magic there's a great name he says there
isn't even a point
in talking about the hypocrisy anymore
we're talking about the left hypocrisy
i have a woke brother and i know
personally that they do not see their
own flaws
and or lack of logical consistency
yeah um i hear this a lot when i point
out the double standards and i'm told
that well there's no point in even
pointing it out anymore because it
doesn't make a difference they don't
care
and that's true by and large
but the problem is number one so what
else are we gonna do
simply accept it if there's a double
standard are we going to
accept it allow it not say anything not
point it out
allow them to pretend unopposed that
there is no double standard
now i think we have to point out and
also keep in mind that um
this is the case with people generally
not just on the left most people are
stubborn and they're not willing to see
the flaws in their thinking
it's not a modern person thing that's
that's simply a person that's a human
nature thing
so when you present arguments and you
stand up and say okay there's a double
standard here
yeah most people on the other side who
hear you are going to dismiss it
because that's how people are
but you got to hope that there are at
least a few people
who even if they don't change their mind
right then and there
you plant the seed you get them thinking
about it
and if they're if they have any capacity
for critical thinking down the line
maybe that's that seed sprouts
and um and uh they start to realize the
truth a little bit
that's why sometimes it could feel so
defeating when you're presenting
arguments to someone
because it's very rare you know when
you're having an argument with anybody
especially a political or ideological
argument it's very rare for someone to
say right then and there oh you know
what you're right i'm going to change my
mind it almost never happens right
does that mean that nobody ever changes
their mind well people just change their
mind it just it's not going to be right
then there on the spot
it might be that night or a day later
two weeks later a year later who knows
you could put them on that path and not
know it and that's why it's worth it to
present the arguments anyway
um
jay mohan says matt to consider 18 year
olds are not responsible for their debt
because they don't know what they're
doing yet they're allowed to vote for
our representatives is a frightening
truth
i totally agree yeah i'm i'm fully on
board with the idea like we talked about
last week that
at 18 years old you got these kids
coming out of high school and they're
taking out these massive loans
and they don't really know what they're
doing and i i agree that they don't
really know what they're doing which is
why
you know there should be some reform to
the system that allows the banks to to
give these loans in the first place
but if we can all agree on that point
which it seems we can
then yeah why are we allowing if if
they're not if if they don't have the
psychological equipment to
make these sorts of financial decisions
which obviously they don't
then why are we letting them make
decisions about the future of the
country
raise the voting age i'm all about that
raise it to 25 30.
35 well not 35 because i'm not 35 yet
but 25 let's say
um and finally rusty dog says matt you
use the phrase
iron out the kinks come on man
it's work out the kinks or iron out the
wrinkles
you move to tennessee now you're mixing
your metaphors like some country bumpkin
cancel yourself well rusty dog first of
all
that bigoted accusation that
stereotypical accusation towards me is
not acceptable and i think iron out the
kinks is a
in fact i looked it up and i found a
wordpress blog someone wrote a blog on
wordpress in 2010
giving the uh the the etymology of iron
out the kinks
and they say that iron out the kinks is
a perfectly acceptable expression
so says the person who wrote this word
press blog in 2010. so you are canceled
and also
banned from the show well i don't know
about you maybe i'm alone in this i
don't think i am maybe i am i don't
enjoy wasting time at the post office i
i personally don't and that's why that's
why i use stamps.com
uh you can mail and ship online at
stamps.comstance.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
could send letters you could ship
packages you could pay
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps ups and more stamps.com
has saved businesses thousands of hours
and tons of money with stamps.com you
get the service of the post office and
ups
all in one place you don't have to go
anywhere you get it right at your house
plus big discounts on mailing and
shipping rates as well
stamps.com brings the services the u.s
postal service and ups right to your
computer
and this is great uh if you're you know
a business owner it's obviously great
because all the mailing that you do all
the time
and money and everything that you're
wasting you can get a lot of that back
by going to stamps.com
but really for anyone stamps.com is the
best option simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24 7 for any
letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule
pick up or drop off it's that simple
with stamps.com
you get discounts up to 40 off post
office rates
and up to 62 percent off ups shipping
rates
so you're saving time it's it's one of
those no-brainer situations your ship
you're saving time
you're saving money why not stamps.com
is the way to go stop wasting time going
to the post office and go to stamps.com
instead there's no risk
and with my promo code walsh you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus
free postage at a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top
of the home page and type in walsh
that's stamps.com
promocodewalshstamps.com
never go to the post office again also
want to invite you to join us this
wednesday february 24th for the
um for this month's backstage we enter
2021 with our debut into the world of
entertainment
and have kept the big news coming most
recently announcing our recent movie
deal with gino carano
you can join us wednesday as we talk
through this and much more in other news
we've also got a new show coming out
this friday featuring our very own ben
shapiro
you know there are so many narratives
around hot topic issues and it's hard to
keep track of all the
newest controversies that the left
decides to be offended by we already
talked about some of those on the show
today which is why you're going to want
to tune in to debunked to see
ben's to see ben expose leftist
fallacies in 15 minutes or less
climate change universal health care
covett policies
all of that facts and logic is what he's
using
this show will be available exclusively
to daily wire members so if you aren't
already a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code debunked to
get 25
off the reasons to join daily wire keep
piling up so use code debunked
for 25 off today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
late last week as we covered on this
show senator ted cruz just talked about
came under intense scrutiny and backlash
after it was revealed
that he had traveled with his family to
cancun during the winter storm disaster
in his state
this was a huge controversy for reasons
that nobody could ever quite explain
even after he revised his plans and
returned home the outrage had not quite
abated
uh in fact the media was tracking cruz's
family his wife and daughters now
in cancun a new york post headline
announced quote ted cruz's family seen
soaking up the cancun sun while texas
shivers
i have to admit that's pretty outrageous
you know ted cruz's daughters
should be back in texas working to fix
the power grid damn lazy kids nowadays
back in my day when there was an outage
my parents had me climb up the pole to
fix the power lines myself that had to
do without shoes too
uphill both ways but these are softer
and more delicate times i suppose
anyway the pr crisis for cruz became an
opportunity for others like
representative alexandria casio cortez
who
shortly after cancungate went viral
announced that she would be traveling to
texas to help out herself
totally coincidental timing i'm sure as
the local abc affiliate in houston
reported aoc quote
toward houston storm damage now
why did a representative from new york
need to fly down to a city a different
state
1600 miles away to tour the storm damage
while the cynical among us might
theorize that this was nothing more than
a glorified
instagram photo shoot in fairness though
she did more than tour the damage
there's also video of her lifting
packages of water bottles and
putting them in people's trunks which is
also nice
but again the cynical those darn cynical
people
might say that the workers and
volunteers taking care of the mess down
to houston
really didn't need a high-profile
politician from up north to fly down
to help pick up water bottles i mean
there's no practical advantage to her
presence there
she brings media she brings probably
extra security
other logistical concerns that vastly
outweigh the benefit
of having her there to put water bottles
in people's trunks and make concerned
facial expressions
while looking at the storm damage i just
i doubt that any emergency worker or
charity volunteer has ever been in the
middle of a crisis
and then stopped to look around and said
to themselves you know what we really
need here you know what we need we need
a famous politician trailed by a line of
journalists with cameras
that would make everything run smoother
if aoc really wanted to provide extra
manpower she could have delegated she
could have sent some people down
or helped to recruit locals she did help
raise money for the storm relief which
is good
but the part where she shows up in
person to lift up water bottles on
camera
that's where you might suspect that
there's more to this than her passion
for charity work
at least a cynical person might think
that let's be fair though she didn't
just tour the storm damage or put water
bottles and trunks
she also of course found a microphone
and a podium to give a speech
and here's some of that you know we
really need to make sure that
we're getting food and assistance to
people across the state as is mentioned
here at the food at the houston food
bank no
questions are asked so you come up and
you need help
you do not have to prove a damn thing
in the houston food bank if you are
documented undocumented
no matter what your income no matter
your housing status
you can get help here which is one of
the reasons why we are so proud to
support the houston food bank
because we don't because we want to help
everybody
you need it we'll be there gee you know
it really looks and sounds like this
woman flew down to texas in the middle
of a natural disaster to pose for
cameras
and deliver a stump speech i mean did
it's the houston
food bank do they need a congresswoman
from new york
to come and speak for them are they not
capable of doing that themselves
what she just said there is was there no
one who actually works at the food bank
bank
no local person that could have gotten
on camera and said all that
that they need to fly heard in to say
that
it looks like she was taking advantage
it looks and sounds that way because
that's exactly what she did
this is after all the same person who
pretended to cry in front of an empty
parking lot near the southern border
let's not forget it's the same people
person who claimed that ted cruz was
trying to kill her
which by the way what are you doing
going down to texas ted cruz is there
you didn't leave you said he's trying to
kill you
putting her out but i guess she's more
more courage from this woman putting her
taking her life into her hands like that
there's also the same woman who claimed
that she had a near-death experience in
the riots even though the rioters never
came
near her or entered the building she was
in she has a history of dramatically
exploiting crises for political gain
and if you have any lingering doubts and
think that maybe she really went to
texas to perform charity work on camera
for entirely benevolent reasons then
consider that communities in her own
state her own city
were devastated over the summer by blm
rioting and she never showed up to help
the victims there
much less give give speeches advocating
for them
she chose texas for a reason
by the way she's also been clear that
people shouldn't be traveling during the
pandemic number one
and people actually shouldn't be
traveling by plane at all because it's
destroying the environment and bringing
mankind to the brink of extinction
it's actually causing exactly the kinds
of weather events that that devastated
texas
according to her you think this would be
all the more reason to not fly to texas
when there is clearly no
practical benefit to her physical
presence in the states
but it wasn't about the practical
benefit except in the sense that
political benefits are
practical now i don't mean to pick on
aoc here she is so
transparently opportunistic that it's
hard not to pick on her but it's not
like she's the first politician
to swoop down into a crisis like this
she wasn't the only politician in the
you know getting in the way down there
in texas even ted cruz
showed up to carry water bottles around
after he got all that guff for trying to
leave town
it's a pretty standard political
procedure uh using a natural disaster as
a campaign event
politicians have been doing that forever
of course but that doesn't make it any
better
ted cruz had it right the first time
it's better for these people to just get
out of the way
than for them to show up for the photo
shoot and that's why
aoc is cancelled am i really canceling
her for doing charity work
yes i am absolutely because it's not
about the charity
at all and if you don't see that if
you're too dumb to see that then well
you're canceled too
and that's gonna do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show dr anthony fauci says
we might be wearing masks into next year
the biden administration refuses to
condemn andrew cuomo's cover-up
and coca-cola is pushing racist
diversity training that's the ben
shapiro show today tune in